By this point in this class, you
must have realized that a
lot of revolves around the
concept of conditioning.
Conditional expectations
play a central role.
For this reason, it is useful
to revisit this concept and
view it in a more
abstract manner.
The basic idea is that the
value of a conditional
expectation is affected by a
random quantity by the value
of the random variable Y on
which we are conditioning.
It is a function of Y and,
therefore, a random variable.
Based on this observation, we
will redefine the conditional
expectation as a random variable
and then try to
understand its properties.
In particular, we will develop
a formula for the expected
value of the conditional
expectation.
This will be what as known
as the law of iterated
expectations.
After doing all this, we will
follow a similar program for
the conditional variance.
Once more, we will see
that it can be
viewed as a random variable.
And then we will relate its
expected value with the
unconditional variance.
This will be the so-called
law of total variance.
As an illustration of the tools
we are introducing in
this lecture, we will consider
various examples that will
hopefully clarify the
concepts involved.
Our final and most important
example will involve the sum
of a random number of
independent random variables.
The setting here is more
challenging than the case
where we add a fixed number
of random variables.
But by using conditioning,
we will be able to derive
formulas for the mean
and the variance.